[Musique]
pensez-vous que demain matin demain
soir
vous lisez succès versus où on a juste
oublié ce que vous avez dit et vous chanterez
votre grand succès et comme si vous arrêtez
encore linea sera seulement l'homme dit lors de
votre mixage avec l'Elysée Montessori
au-delà vous  parle
pas très bien le français personne ne peut dire
quelque chose pour nous très amorphe je pourrais
dire c'est une soirée ou patron la
demence ainsi mr.  Fisher
comment êtes-vous heureux d'être à nouveau dans ce je l'ai
laissé donne-nous la bouteille très beau
cadeau
aimez-vous les gens qui sont dans ce
John alors votre nuisance est un
Bernard Shaw alors oui nous avons des gagnants
sur la sauce mascara sauce sur un bon
cocktails
[Musique]